today I receive a message hi it's the
tournament director I understand you are
filming and interviewing at the
tournament this weekend in order to
publish anything you need explicit
permission from me at the University
which this is a bit funny because girls
uh film all the time at tournaments I
see them filming footage and everybody I
interviewed I have expressed permission
and everybody I interviewed I
interviewed outside of the tournament
because it was so loud in there but okay
it was so it's like why do they get in
the middle of it when this is between me
and the people and I can blur out their
faces whatever as you didn't obtain this
you have not you do not have permission
to use these recordings from the event
there were minors no there were no there
were no miners in my videos and
vulnerable adults on the site so I'm
like what is a vulnerable adult you know
vulnerable adults are me yeah and the
other women that are forced to play
against these men